.
MORE FROM BARBIE NADEAU.
SHE'S BEEN FOLLOWING THIS FROM
ROME.
>> ALL INDICATORS POINT TO A
VERY COMFORTABLE VICTORY FOR
THE CENTER RIGHT COALITION IN
ITALY'S GENERAL ELECTION.
THIS COALITION WAS LED BY THE
FAR-RIGHT BROTHERS OF ITALY
PARTY, LED BY GIORGIA MELONI
WHO IS NOW ON TRACK TO BE IN
THESE FIRST EVER FEMALE PRIME
MINISTER.
SHE CAN PAINT ON STRONG FAMILY
VALUES.
THIS WAS ANGERED BY THE DONALD
TRUMP LOVING --
THEY CAMPAIGNED ON ANTI
IMMIGRATION AND SECURE BORDERS.
THE OTHER ANCHOR OF THIS
COALITION IS A LONGTIME
POLITICIAN IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
COMPLETE OCCULT LEGEND WHO
THREE TIMES WAS ELECTED TO
PRIME MINISTER THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT THIS VICTORY MEANS, THIS
WILL BE THE FIRST TIME SINCE
THE END OF WORLD WAR II AND THE
FALL OF FASCISM THAT ITALY HAS
BEEN LED BY SUCH A FAR RIGHT
LEADING COALITION GOVERNMENT.
BARBIE NADEAU, CNN, ROME.
>> EARLIER, I SPOKE WITH NADIA,
SHE'S THE PROFESSOR AT COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY.
I SPOKE TO HER ABOUT THESE
ELECTIONS.
SHE OFFERED HER PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT HOW GEORGIA MALONEY WILL
LEAD IF SHE IS NAMED PRIME
MINISTER.
LISTEN.
>> THE COALITION MAYBE WE.
THIS MAY PUSH HER TO BE MORE
AND LESS RADICAL.
POLITICAL ECONOMIC DECISIONS,
SHE IS NOT AS RADICAL AS THE
FAR-RIGHT.
MOSTLY BECAUSE YOU CANNOT USE
LEGITIMATE SHE WANTS.
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR THAT.
SO, SHE CANNOT REALLY DO WHAT
SHE WANTS IN ANY CASE.
PARTICULARLY NOW.
PERSPECTIVE IS NOT A STRONG
GOVERNMENT.
PERHAPS A DIFFICULT GOVERNMENT
WILL BE PUT TO GATHER.
>> HOW DOES THIS WORK IN TERMS
OF THE COMPLEXION OF
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS EUROPE?
WE'VE CERTAINLY SEEN THE RIGHT
AND ITALY, WE'VE HAD IT IN
HUNGARY FOR A WHILE.
WE'RE GETTING TO SEE THAT IN
SWEDEN, AS WELL.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT EUROPE AND
ITALY'S PLACE WITHIN IT, DO YOU
THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
PRESSURE TO HOLD MORE
RIGHT-OF-CENTER OPINIONS AND
MORE RADICAL POLICY POSITIONS?
MAYBE EVEN ON UKRAINE?
BERLUSCONI HAS ALREADY COME AS
IF TRYING TO EXCUSE PUTIN'S
BEHAVIOR.
>> YES, THIS WAS ALREADY THERE
BEFORE THESE ELECTIONS.
CERTAINLY.
THE POSITION TO PUTIN IN
ITALY'S VERY COMPLEX.
IT'S NOT BLACK AND WHITE.
BOTH IN THE LEFT AND IN THE
RIGHT.
THERE IS A KIND OF CONSERVATIVE
WINDOW IN EUROPE.
BOTH BECAUSE OF THE CARBON AND
[INAUDIBLE] AND THE CRISIS OF
ENERGY, WHICH MEANS ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS.
THIS AFFECTION WITH THE EUROPE
OF RIGHT AND THE BEACON OF
RIGHTS, IN SOME SENSES AND
DECLINE.
NOW, THE SENSE IS THAT THAT
NATION STATES, THEY WANT TO
HAVE MORE POWER AND THEY WANT
MORE ABILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS.
AND THERE AUTONOMY.
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY, AS THEY SAY,
NOT WITHIN A QUASI-COMMUNITY OF
THE UNITY.
SO,